ladies and gentlemen we've made it to
the finale of hawkeye today so koi
jondro is not with us today if you
follow him on social media he has
unveiled that he he caught the vidcon
okay that's what's going on right now it
won't be the same without him so with
that in mind uh we we gave him a spot
right here just just so his presence is
with us
during this time because we will not
forget you coy energy
triple fisting to make up for the fact
that he can't be here yeah those are his
jeans i ran by his place made sure to
kiss him on the lips on the way out and
he loves deadpool and spidey and uh oh
man you caught it the wrong week buddy i
don't care what you're dealing with koi
this is more important unprecedented
anything else i know you did this on
purpose
but send him some love guys anywho if
you could go ahead and hit that like
button that would be amazing thank you
to the boys over prepper for helping us
edit down these highlights full-length
watch alongs of course it'll be at our
patreon page you can't super reject by
checking us out over there cover a bunch
of shows let's see if we actually get
ourselves a king to the pin in person
today
[Music]
[Music]
wasted no time
what i'd expect when there's a debt
and your husband owed a small fortune oh
okay
and that's where i draw the line there
are no lines in this business and that
is why i have to leave this business
don't be rash i want you to know
that i have been keeping an insurance
policy
oh
i'm gonna give you a minute to think
about what you're starting right now
i don't need a minute
oh damn i love how he was cast by the
purple in the back yeah right there
oh that's great that video kate is it's
not good
yeah kingpin will not take this lightly
yeah
and he's gonna do it a big way
[Laughter]
you should be with your family you can
still make it in time for christmas kate
you're my partner
your mess is my mess
i'm not going anywhere until this is
finished that's good [ __ ] huh right
cheers buddy
i got carried away you know what my
father meant to me
to all of us
[Music]
if it's okay with you i'd like a couple
of days off to clear my head
perhaps investigate some things
on my own under the radar
we need a ton of gear
like a whole batch of way too dangerous
trick arrows
oh
where you going
[Music]
this arrow turns into a mach 2 suit this
is the nanotech here
[Laughter]
it's pretty cool we actually got a scene
of him building the arrows wow jack's
out of jail already
it's kind of sword if i get sword on it
i found her
[Music]
okay
hi mom come with me
[Music]
no
surprise surprise
[Music]
get down
oh
nice work
good use of platter
find illinois
all right head okay throw the fire away
copy that
we're going position two guys wendy and
missy kill the lights you better not
hurt grills
so i know you're chummy with my mom but
i gotta say i didn't think you'd make
the cut for the christmas party
no
whoa that was a great transition yeah
wowza damn what was that
come on that is so annoying
[Laughter]
oh
come on get your suit
get the suit man
i mean it's christmas eve let's grab a
drink huh
okay yeah cool sure
after i kill barton
no no that no that's not what come on
listen you don't get anything
why doesn't elena just like knock her
out okay yeah i feel like she could
whoa
nice
[Music]
bye
wow wow cool cool shot
[Music]
is that you
oh oh no no no no
no
[Music]
oh damn that's a great shot yeah
[Music]
bones popping out and everything
got you now bro
oh nice
[Music]
oh
i'm so threatened by kazu right now
oh
yeah
oh no
ah
[Laughter]
i need to get to my own disney plus
series
there's not enough room in this show for
me
[Applause]
oh [ __ ]
let's do this
we're all gonna die
[Music]
repeat after me i'm not gonna do
anything incredibly stupid
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they knock over a real tree for this
year
until exposed let's go take off the
white shirt [ __ ] hold them off for a bit
nice
great there's only about a thousand of
them and two of us
twist the brochures
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
wow what a wide array of arrows
[Music]
oh what are you doing is that the pin
arrow
what happens to them now
i don't know
i'll tell scott about that one
oh no
i suspect the post-credits scene what is
that oh bro
yeah the best shots are the ones raised
out looking
[Music]
my life
it was never supposed to be yours
don't make me do this maya you know i
just don't feel like you're you can kick
her ass man
[Laughter]
don't make me attempt to do this
holy [ __ ]
don't leave eleanor
come here
how about more comic book he is yeah
what are you gonna do with that
i'm gonna bounce off him
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
nobody killed her
she made a choice stop lying
damn foreign such a good actress yeah
mind your own business
my god
try to do the leg thing on me you're
really starting to annoy me
she did it
the cuff link and everything
[Music]
too dangerous wow
wow
it's like a boss level fight in the game
yeah mom okay
are you okay
she like turned the car back and yeah
she did three points
pulled down the parallel parking job
you're under arrest for the murder of
armand de caine iii turn around please
you're gonna need a good lawyer justice
doesn't take a holiday
[Music]
clint knows the whistle
she loved you and always wanted you safe
you got so much time with her
it shouldn't have gone this way
if i was there i could have stopped it i
could i could have changed it nothing
was going to stop her atlanta he knew to
tell you
she made her choice
we're gonna have to find a way to live
with that i loved her so much
me too
[Music]
where you go elena and what's val gonna
say what a surprise
maya
you and i
we're family
family
sometimes family doesn't see
eye to eye
what the [ __ ]
uh
i mean kingpin can't be dead yeah they
panned up there's gotta be something
going on
and that missy boy she just
outdid herself with his suit right the
elasticity
i missed you
oh i missed you too did you bring my
watch brought home a couple strays
hi this is kate um kate
[ __ ] i'm just gonna officially gonna
come live with them huh you're never
gonna guess what was found in a black
market auction in new york city
thank you
[ __ ] shot like hot like hot shot but but
you know [ __ ] yeah
lady arrow
okay fine you know what actually i have
an idea
[Music]
nice
well [ __ ]
interesting like
got some mixed feelings about some of
this
for sure
liked a lot and then uh
you process a couple other things for
you i'll jump down my throat now only
unanimous praise here it's gotta be a
post-credits scene it's keeping just
pulling a bullet out of his head
oh
so annoying
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah i'm so glad they did this i am
too a little bit of christmas cheer
[Applause]
i hope they put that on youtube i think
that is their postcard soon
seems like it well that's the end of
kingpin yeah he's dead done
was that koi
ah
yeah you see if uh if coy was here he
would tell you that this might be a
possible spoiler uh what we're about to
say
is that and i know some of you guys
already typed it because you guys like
the second we have a reaction to
something
kinkman's not dead most likely just
blind
right that's what we're gonna say is
that we're gonna say is that what some
of you guys are gonna say some of your
top comments don't worry before you go
yeah yeah is this what happens in the
comic okay okay glad we got that out of
the way good good good
a sign mockingbird is that what you're
gonna say yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
19. yeah it's amazing how much came true
that was the arrest
it's amazing just how much it came true
yeah it looks like kingpin will probably
come back uh in echo series and there's
a lot to digest here there's a lot to uh
a lot to think about here john kick us
off what's the first subject to talk
about i mean i think the first subject
to talk about is
just the lovely wrap-up we got between
kate and and clint i mean you know this
was a nice sort of realization of their
unit as a team as partners accepting one
another as family even and especially
for the holidays i thought that was a
nice
aspect to this that tied it all together
because i think there will probably be
some things that we both enjoyed and
some things that we have maybe uh some
uh
questions or qualms about but i thought
that that really nicely tied everything
together whoa john john listen if we
disagree on anything
remember i'm judging you for how you
think and feel oh yeah according to of
course some comments i saw in the matrix
yeah i apparently i i can't stomach
the thought
of you having a different opinion than
me
it's never happened
my god got a little emotional with uh
with kate and um with that no you're
elena and clint didn't you yeah you got
pretty emotional i didn't realize just
how much you
cared about black widow when you lane
all the sudden that's right man i
realized that it was all fake i faked it
i was like oh man it's finale
i know what's going on it's not a finale
until one of us is cried and you're
clearly not doing it so you got to pick
up the load yeah activate those acting
skills
channel tears yeah
because we all know how much you love
black widow yes i particularly
and we all know two of us we all know
that between the two of us you liked it
more than i did yeah you thought it was
okayer than i did you gave it more of
the benefit of the doubt that i did
exactly i had to make up for being
i just felt like i didn't feel as
strongly about that scene like i
appreciate the whole context and thought
it was beautifully acted yeah and one of
the best written parts of the episode
too
but because i didn't get the tears
to help oh yeah
this is yeah
and uh kingpin is definitely dead
yeah 100 uh you by the camera panda
um so yeah uh i i mean yeah that is one
of the best scenes of the episode it
brings a good resolution
uh and an arc to the whole thing
especially because
you know uh natasha has been such a such
like a character in this whole series
from from the very first episode right
when clint was watching rogers the
musical
and uh the way how the the camera worked
and the audio
um did it's like going into his
perspective and they had some motifs
that they've seen in other episodes
where honestly koi you know i'm so used
to you being here we've done plenty of
reviews without you for many videos and
many uncut reviews without you but
because of the fact that it's hawkeye
i'm just so used to you being here that
i can't stop thinking about like oh this
is kind of weird that koi's not here
so yeah yeah um and it's also kind of
weird that i'm saying it's weird koi's
not here but i'm also doing a bit as if
koi is here so it's not really panning
out of my favorite layers so many layers
so many layers um but yeah i i think
that is one of the best parts of this
whole series especially is you know
after a avengers end game then there was
like a grief tony stark and spider-man
you know uh far from home and it seemed
to be a lot of like the long of tony but
not much paid in tribute to black widow
then she gets her own movie and this to
me really dealt a lot with the loss of
of natasha because the way we experience
grief is through the ones who are still
alive to have to deal with the suffering
of that and the ones who have easily
most likely
suffered the most of anyone it would
have to be
you know clint barton and elena
and then coming to this
understanding and i think florence
pugh's acting in that scene is
phenomenal because you know it's like
it's so easy for her to probably just
find that sense of i can close the
chapter on this if i just get my revenge
i just need to know why and then get my
revenge and then maybe just maybe you
know being someone who's raised an
assassin i could finally put this [ __ ]
behind me i could finally put a seal on
this so you know when she's like in
denial of what clint is saying and she's
hitting him just fighting against it it
felt so human and every time florence
pew is on screen she is just the star
she is just stealing it even in some
scenes in this finale where i was like
i feel weird about this scene or i'm not
really liking this scene all that much
she's always great she's always
phenomenal and that scene in particular
does allow for
some type of
semblance of closure for them it's like
it's not something they'll get over
especially clint who has to live with
this but he can continue to live and
keep carrying on
um and that's like the the difference
between the two of them in that scene so
yeah i thought i thought it was
absolutely beautiful and i hope a lot of
you guys got brought to tears in that
moment and i'm glad you did john
thanks man i appreciate the support like
a corner right here okay flick a quarter
euro what's next john oh well i mean
obviously some of the best action in the
episode while we're on the topic of
elena came from her i mean that sequence
where they're fighting through the you
know level of the building office you
know was pretty great and uh you know
watching old boy exactly like watching
old boys but in this light hearted semi
kind of violent
network-esque show um and then you know
all the trick arrows and stuff like that
finally get to see them in their suits
like i feel like plaza's ice skating
rink showdown that was cool right yeah
and i mean i feel like you know these
were all probably made as a batch but
from last week uh you know i feel like
they really must have known when they
got uh uh
florence pugh and haley steinfeld in a
room together how great the two of them
interact and so you know it was nice to
get a nice little like both fight but
also like that elevator scene where
they're both kind of sizing each other
up and competing and just the the weird
ways in which they could be friends and
they are very similar despite this one
particular barrier so i have a feeling
that we'll have to see more of uh
elena and kate together in the future
just because their chemistry is is so
wonderful
um but yeah they play off each other
well
and this was an interesting episode too
because you know you have elena here
obviously you've got kingpin i feel like
this was kind of a lot of stuff
happening kind of all around the same
area and it felt maybe a little chaotic
uh and like the all of a sudden for the
what
huh no no i thought you were laughing
yeah that's the way the show starts oh i
think i think it's i think it is a lot i
think they i think they jam-packed a
little too much into this one episode
yeah which has never been heard of of a
marvel third act finale or movies or
shows ever
yeah and being the way we started out
with the first two episodes it felt like
it was gonna be something a lot more
streamlined or a lot more focused
and so yeah this episode had a lot of
really cool appearances and some really
cool fights and whatnot but it did feel
a bit i guess chaotic and you've got a
lot of things being paid off very
quickly like eleanor and her connection
too
isn't chaotic the point because this is
a chaotic situation sure but uh it
doesn't it still needs to feel like it
was all proportioned and paced over the
course of the show in some kind of way
that feels smooth and thought out i mean
chaos can feel intentional or it can
feel like it's the product of the
management or the you know cramming in
of characters and plot lines and i feel
like we lean more towards the latter
with aspects of this show like the whole
i've been waiting for this episode to
kind of know how i feel about the
overall pace and structuring and it does
seem like it has this sort of odd
structure and the way the episode goes
is pretty straightforward
i think what was happening here
uh was that the first two episodes had a
much more christmasy light-hearted vibe
about it
and then as we all saw in episode three
it started taking more serious turn
didn't get like full hardcore like it
definitely had more of the gravitas and
then there were other episodes that
probably bought a little bit more
dramatic half but
i would say uh after episode two
things definitely started having more
scenes that featured a lot more drama
and a lot more weight
and then i think in terms of like movie
chapters usually they try to like have
it be like bookended right whereas like
you see similarities in the beginning so
you can kind of match the journey in the
arc so that tonally provide that
christmas
tone to it you see like where the lark
people are at with them in their
relationship now you especially see with
kate who's a much more confident fighter
in this episode as she's fighting
multiple you know um
i got tracksuit mafia people uh fighting
them and where in the first one she's
like kind of you know in her head a lot
and feels like she's really just
improvising here she's a really
confident fighter
and uh there was another moment too with
kate that ah what was it oh yeah the she
fails with the clock like blows it up
and then here she you know it look like
again a bookend uh she shoots down the
tree successfully she aims and she blows
up another thing but she does it well in
style and to their benefit versus uh you
know messing up right so you have like
those touches and those uh
additional nuances to it so i could see
what they were going for
um however
i i did
um not want to immediately jump to
things that i want to kind of uh oh well
reserve a little bit more criticisms
what else was good john
that's good uh we'll get there i mean it
was it was definitely nice to at least
get to the bottom of what was going on
with eleanor and i liked as much as
we've been speculating as much as there
are these kind of red herring characters
like jack i thought that was kind of a
charming turn of like oh i guess he's
just all right in this universe or in
this iteration of the character and
that's like a ralph boner thing that at
least to my sensibility is not anger
inducing and i was like oh cool nice
like i've been suspicious of this guy
the whole time and and then on the
opposite side of that coin with eleanor
i like that it's not like okay and now
here's a massive reveal that she's some
important villain it was more like yeah
your dad got us into this really nasty
situation and this was the best way i
knew how to deal with it and their back
and forth you know there's there's a
hard kind of divide that doesn't have a
christmasy resolve or kind of like it'll
be all right aside from the circumstance
like you know it seems like there is
a tangible sacrifice and a tangible
split in ideology and and conflict that
ends off between kate and eleanor that i
thought was was nicely handled for the
amount of like oh is there gonna be some
kind of big easter egg reveal like i
kind of liked that they didn't have to
do that for this
um
and you know for who for eleanor well i
think they are setting her up to be
madame mask sure but in this here and
now i like that even the way that's
being played is still the gradual
because i feel like in a finale like
this it would be really easy to go oh
we're setting this up we're setting this
up we're setting this up you know here's
a bunch of clues and easter eggs for the
future and i like that they didn't let
that eclipse what they were doing just
in this episode with those characters
like for here and now the story they're
telling it seems like they chose to
service that instead of service [ __ ] to
expect for the future you know and i
think with clint in particular i mean
he's definitely the one who's grown the
most out of anyone
like kate had to accept the reality of
the situation of you know the the
hardships of being a hero the reality of
her family
um
the the whole thing about especially
with like having to turn in her mother
you know this is uh the hard sacrifices
and the choice of tough decisions you
gotta make because it's the right thing
to do ultimately just because she's your
mom you know people get canceled for
[ __ ] like that these days
remember chris cuomo did and then
it's the same thing yeah
allegory one to one story 101. this
movie just all marvel curious about is
their puzzles
and
and uh
and then with clint you know he's like
definitely learn more uh i like having
the the vulnerability and letting people
in making kate partner and not more than
that like you're part of the family now
we're taking you home you're you're my
new daughter but also a partner and also
friend and i'm going to tell you more
[ __ ] that i'm gonna tell myself
yeah
yeah well that was that was kind of
funny to me it was like oh man they had
such a heartwarming sort of uh growth
and bond together
and he does take her home but yeah i'm
like you were teaching your actual
daughter how to shoot and now it seems
like this is just transferred over onto
kate that's the daughter he never had
right here which i mean to be fair if i
was clint i wouldn't want my actual
daughter getting into this [ __ ] i would
rather it be somebody who just will not
give up on it you know well she's close
to being an adult and at the end of the
day she's still um a minor so she needs
a place to live sure yeah i'm just not
going to say her shitty hands please
nope screw that
she could be kept safe there too at
clint's
the off the grid location um yeah that
was really nice and clint got to be with
his family i wish we got a little bit
more family time since that's gonna be
his big motivator i would have liked
like an actual coda with them yeah i
think this would probably would have
been benefited best from two two
episodes yeah
this i think they could have done
everything here with two episodes and it
would have flowed perfectly well
uh i yeah because i do jam pack a lot in
here this is the best that
okay where to begin let's start with
jack
i'm gonna i'm not even gonna talk about
comics i could give two shits about the
whole swordsman thing all right i like i
i don't really i i never really cared
about swordsman from the comics right
even though that's who this is rift off
of clearly that's not something i'm like
man they did [ __ ] didn't do the
swordsman did jacques dirty
there are beats here that really rubbed
me the wrong way
part of the endearing aspect with
eleanor was the fact that when you get
those scenes like when when jack is
quoting things wrong and how like he's
so in love with eleanor and trying to be
a step dad
and
um you know like like some of those
scenes where you're like oh maybe he is
a good guy so that's fine to me that
like oh he actually was just
a good guy he was just a dude
and
but then it became like a cartoon to me
about him and i
kind of didn't i really didn't like that
there was nothing about with him
after fighting the people you know yeah
he's just a wrap up there's it's not
yeah there's nothing about being
dismayed or perturbed by the fact that
eleanor sent him to jail and eleanor is
a big criminal and he was wrongly
accused he did wrongly yeah
yeah he went to prison like i don't know
the extent of how much he knows he's got
to know she's been arrested and
you see these experiences where he's
like fighting off bad guys and it's just
like uh it's cartoony to me
and yes it's a marvel comic adaptation
series but
i feel like the characters suddenly got
diminished a just a joke in the moment
and that's what it just turned that's
just plain and simple what it turned
into there's nothing no
not even a moment of reaction about what
happened maybe we can all theorize about
like hey maybe he actually knows more
than he was letting on well and like you
guys can probably make assumptions fill
in blanks make theories but from what
the episode itself presented in the
season finale wasn't a big fan of that
i really thought the first half of this
episode
that's where a lot of my issues actually
lie like do i think they were kind of
doing too much in a 60 minute thing
there's so many plot lines
the first half of this is where most of
my issues where i think
it started to really
affect me negatively
was while every
scene there's no scene here i was like f
that scene there's not a single scene
that makes me feel that way
it's more that it was
a little it was a little too
light-hearted for me to the point where
there was
zero tension it starts off in a way like
you think you're gonna get it
you know like oh that's immediately
swinging a kingpin right away and i have
thoughts about that let's immediately
swing in a kingpin right away and it's
exciting to see vincent d'onofrio back
right that's what it's playing on or if
you're or if you didn't watch daredevil
but you like the comics
you know so there's that
and it's it's like a serious steak scene
but then
that's what i meant by elena and kate
that kind of started rubbing me the
wrong way was as great as they are with
working off of each other
like this this arguably should be a
really tense thing this should arguably
be an intense situation is that
the chaos she was just feeling like
a fun little christmas thing
when
it it's like she the first episode she's
introduced she's trying to kill him the
second episode she tries to get to to uh
to kate and it's a real like
tarantino-esque back and forth the
dialogue there's a lot of tension in
there
and then here it just becomes marvel
comedy again
and
there's like no real pulse to her trying
to go after clint she's walking casually
it's just fun just like funny he's it's
funny you know you never treat it like
it could actually happen they never it's
like of course it wouldn't they don't
even try to they don't even make an
attempt to so they just go for jokes
let's make a joke fight scene let's make
a joke thing with the elevator let's
let's just make it jokey jokey jokey
when i'm like she's on a mission to kill
this guy and i you don't feel any of the
suspense of that
of clint's trying to do a job but he
also has elena coming after him right
now so like the build up to that i
thought was weak
and uh that really let me down a lot
because uh yo
like literally three through five i
really like the two of them i loved not
one of those i really liked a lot so i'm
by no means like a person who doesn't
like this show
so
yeah it was it was just all a lot of it
was just so lighthearted and then the
fact that there was so much going on i
want you guys to to do this little
journey with me here
kingpin uh wilson fisk
let's say you never watch daredevil you
couldn't give a [ __ ] about it okay let's
eliminate that out of the category
um let's say you know nothing about
kingpin from the comics just cut that
out of the category just look at the
show itself and the and the writing and
what they're building up to
is
they're building up the big guy there's
a bad guy there's a big baddie coming
right that's what they're saying this is
what they're teasing this whole time
and then at the very end of the last
episode who's my mother with who's this
guy kingpin it's like okay we finally
know who the big bad is i'm saying
eliminate all things of preconceived
anticipation of kingpin from the comics
or vincent d'onofrio returning if it was
just brand new spanking new right here
in this series
i felt like they almost didn't do
anything with it it feels like a side
device rather than the big bad above all
of these things we've been dealing with
this whole time like it feels oddly
detached for being the guy at the head
of all this trouble
it doesn't yeah amplify anything it
doesn't
like really
you know they were building it up so
much of the big bad
that the most a lot of the focus ought
to have been there for your big villain
that you were building up to
and it's
it's just like
so passable of what they did here
you know oh maya i love you and then
that it doesn't become about a hunt to
kill maya
maya's just like
like that whole thing it didn't feel
focused and the thing is that because
there's so much they're cutting around
to
like i i'm excited because i like
kingpin
from every iteration i've seen him in
whether it be comics games show vincent
d'onofrio i really love so i'm excited
personally and i do appreciate more of
the comic book vibe when sometimes it
feels a little bit at odds admittedly i
don't know
if that's only because
the vince d'onofrio in daredevil is very
specifically tuned for daredevil in the
sense of this is a very realistic you
know um
depressed
shell of a human being
this
kind of
like it feels very apparent that this is
not the same version
um they don't try to acknowledge the
past or anything like that this doesn't
feel like this is the same version of
kingpin from that
and vincent d'onofrio's approach is so
real like when he does his acting it's
so like
this the pathos he brings to it is so
real but then
it shucks the pose with this
light-hearted thing around it
like it's it's like so comic book-y in
the in the sense of what it is and then
the tone of this show
that that level of grit
and i can't tell if that's just from my
own
you know preconceived notions and and
emotions
applied towards uh what we've seen of
vincent offrio in two seasons of
daredevil and uh episode and a half of
of season two of daredevil
but i think in terms of just your big
baddie
it
like like what was the most like i if i
would be like what was the big build up
about like what really what was what was
the big build-up about with you know
what well it never builds beyond the
reveal at the end of the last episode no
it doesn't build to anything then the
scene like this he has he fights kate
okay cool
um there's a neat fight but you still
don't feel like he would rage out the
same way if he had the opportunity he
was he didn't seem like heavily involved
in the mix i guess i guess what the show
wanted me to do was feel really
concerned for eleanor
to some extent but i'm also dealing with
the reveal of eleanor we're not really
spending much time with eleanor
and so we're cutting because here here's
everything you're doing in this one
episode
you know elena
clint elena and clint
kate elena and kate
kate and clint
uh tracksuit mafia
eleanor
jack
kazzy
kingpin
uh maya the maya story which is just
okay i guess it's just a setup for a
hawkeye uh echo i mean
and so there's
larp people you know there's so much
happening in here i've named like 10
things just that a lot that's not even
everything that's like 10 things they're
doing in this one
um one episode
that in 60 minutes
it doesn't feel like this is merely
enough to give anything proper service
to really
let your emotions properly latch onto a
lot i think the most they left breathe
well was elena and clint
um but to me i think the use of just big
bad again not saying kingpin not saying
um
vincent de nofuro like that i'm saying
just the use of your build to a big bad
it was like
felt really generic if you asked me then
it felt pretty generic and like oh i
guess he's also surprisingly insanely
strong yeah yeah i guess that's that's
kind of the overarching gripe i would
have with this wrap up is yeah
everything is kind of
lacking in a tension and as much as i
liked that scene with elena and clint i
feel like i would have had a much more
emotional response had there been a
better sense for
the rage and the pain in elena because
yeah like there's so much of that that
has played light and you're also meeting
all these characters now especially in
this episode the show
has given you glimpses and windows into
characters like eleanor certainly like
maya kazi through maya but especially in
this episode it feels like
they could have benefited from a more
ensemble treatment
than it's pretty much still the kate and
and clint show which is good which is
fine but it also
with more expansion and development on
characters like eleanor especially a
little more on jack like any of these
people it would have felt more
meaningful and more impactful and here
it feels more like you know kind of a
fun movie wrap up which isn't like out
of the realm of what they're doing here
but it also yeah it feels very light and
it feels like a lot was introduced
too little consequence other than we can
expect to see it in the future in other
media
and so yeah like kingpin now at the end
of this episode feels more like a stunt
than an actual thing that they wanted to
use to their advantage to drive the
story home or to elevate the sense of
danger or anything like that and even
then you look at this guy and you're
like why would he
even bother with the trek suits because
they're so kind of wacky they like they
are
pretty just silly for most of it
and you know i mean like qazi here is a
little
a little too little too late in terms of
like you know that
between him and maya could have been
much more impactful if
a he had been maybe a little more on par
with who he is in the comics and be if
they had allowed for more than just
the kind of main slash standard beats
for that kind of relationship
it's like you're allowed i feel like in
a show like this a certain number of
action movie and buddy movie tropes to
play with but i feel like there are a
lot of things that don't really rise
above that
especially in this episode and it feels
kind of like okay now we just gotta wrap
things up the way we normally would yeah
i was it was very by the numbers and
that my biggest issue is yeah i felt
like it
it was too much and they rushed
and there was lack of suspense and
tension and it seems like they tried
making up for a lot of that by just
making it fun
and it ultimately didn't feel fun
because i was just on a journey that was
really tension filled for a few episodes
in a row
and now you've eliminated all that
tension suddenly
and that really sucked
like that that bothered me a lot that's
why that first half was really
really upsetting to me yeah i feel like
this episode like you're absolutely
right this could have benefited from
being two episodes so that you could
have your big
you know i mean if you look at a lot of
shows that have a an action
bias or slant i feel like your second to
last episode is often the big physical
showdown of everything colliding all the
different people who are at odds having
their reckoning and then in the last
episode you have you know parts of that
carry over and solved by the middle and
then you can have your codas and then we
could have our little you know actual
some some actual like heartwarming
family time with clint's family at the
end to really relish in how sweet it is
to finally have achieved that after it
looking like he wouldn't make it home at
all for christmas you know or something
like that well i think that yeah this
one should have if there were two
episodes it could have been you
reintroduce kingpin even especially if
it's a new version reintroduce him
really see what this big villain is that
you've been building up to is all about
and the threat that he really opposes
you know like clint seems scared of this
guy for some reason clint was like who
is this guy
clint seemed like really intimidating
i'm like why
and
um so you build that up you build up
maya developing this distrust and trying
to understand like you deal with that
you deal with maya and having to
let that debate but yeah for her like
these things
and then to me it was like we gotta wrap
this up then yeah that's what this
fellow you gotta wrap this up yeah i
feel like especially for maya's story it
comes down to she finds out the truth in
the last episode or or at least the
truth is posed to her she puts it
together and then in this episode it's
pretty much nope he's he's exactly my
enemy now like i feel like it would have
to be to be truly like rich it would
have had to have been harder because she
still has a relationship with him and
there is like a betrayal that would lead
to where this leads to naturally but i
feel like it would benefit from that
emotional turmoil of finding out that
somebody who's been there for you all
your life who you thought was your dad's
you know like a brother to him almost
you know your uncle
you know i felt like they could have
done more justice by that storyline
especially the same way they could have
done more justice to elena's storyline
and then also kate having to deal with
the repercussions of learning about her
mom being involved with this guy like
really let
these revelations and reveals
like let them play let them play and
then you go into your big finale
crescendo where everything's collapsing
and colliding together
and and so yeah this felt so
overconvoluted to me and uh it didn't
like while there were some moments i was
like oh [ __ ] like that when it started
off i was like this is gonna be crazy
and then
it wasn't and so yeah unfortunately
that's just where i'm at with this
and uh i just thought it was weird that
was about i thought it was weird just
how like detached it suddenly became and
did it stick to its guns on what is what
the show had been building to yeah they
just jam-packed too much plot and i
think qazi especially is
like completely again forget the comics
cause kazi it's hard for me to feel
threatened by this guy when i'm like
this guy seems like he kind of sucks at
this job for the most part
you know like the guy is a good actor i
think the guy who plays him is a good
actor this portrayal is a good actor but
you know like oh my god cause he's
threatened sniper oh cause he's gonna
fight clinton like what the [ __ ] what is
he gonna do whatever
he kicked this guy like it was just like
there's no way this guy stands a
fighting chance against clinton now one
part of my your brain is gonna go
this guy can be formidable against him
like
honestly like why why would you think
that why would you possibly think that
from anything we've seen of this guy
and then him taking on my it's like same
thing like what are you talking about
you answered her there's no way why why
would i possibly be don't make me do
this and i'm watching the scene going
what do you mean she's going to whoop
your ass dude yeah man
you're a henchman no like you're a
glorified henchman essentially and she's
like the elite assassin of your group
yeah even if you have a higher status in
the politics of the track suit she can
kick your ass left because they suddenly
started giving so much attention to him
here
and i'm like i don't really care about
you and also you're not threatening one
bit yeah and uh
yeah that was uh that was it and we like
literally the kingpin part is very
disappointing in the sense that bill and
share big baddie because
you build to him and what do you see him
do
he gets in kate's way and that's about
the most of it it's weird like for as
big of a personal twist as that is it
feels yeah just very detached from from
everything it feels like and i mean even
the the the send-off between kate and
eleanor is a little
it's like i liked the performance from
vera farmiga and i liked what she says
but it's not really like
an emotional moment very much and yeah
it should be this big
shocking thing of like she's in bed with
the most you know ruthless
king crime
[ __ ] kid doesn't even talk about it
yeah okay like literally you've just
sent your mom to jail there you have
melancholy or something yeah there
should be something there we're like in
the ambulance with clint like there
should be something there where
it's there's so much they did not do
that uh and then i i i
i don't i just don't get it you know
like i i don't i don't understand
um yeah they only had six episodes and
maybe that's the problem uh well yeah
and and i feel like all of this could
have also
enhanced the christmas vibe because all
these painful divisions are happening at
christmas and i feel like there is a
pantheon of well-loved and poignant
bitter sweet christmas set movies that
you could have easily drawn from and
hearken to because those threads and
flavors have been in the earlier
episodes especially through clint and so
even here like that stuff didn't really
pay or or it's like they had a bunch of
threads that they were braiding together
into something nice and then at the end
they're just all the threads again you
know i mean if you watch any of our
reviews
for a while you'll see that
we don't really ever harp even if it's a
great post-credits scene that's usually
not what we talk about
um we don't like beat that horse size um
but i gotta say man like
as happy as i am to see the rogers the
musical thing i am also like
this would have been fine as a youtube
video
this would have been fine as an upload
on youtube honestly or as the post post
credits scene like yeah like usually the
mid correct the the because there's not
one episode has a post credit scene yeah
and and with as much of like oh man
kingpin and all these other things you
would expect that and i feel like marvel
has trained us to expect that the uh the
mid-credits scene is of is of some kind
of consequence down the line and then
the post-post-credit scene is something
like cheeky and fun and it's like a
little gift or a little reward or
something like that and yeah like i i
really appreciate the sentiment of like
happy holidays from marvel studios but
even the wrap-up didn't feel as
holiday-ish as it could have like it
ends at christmas that's nice
but it really feels like okay we're all
wrapped up and now we're going home and
now the episode's over yeah yeah
and i mean there's the there's the thing
with the watch that gets paid off and
that was nice like that was a a nice
moment i like that linda carter kind of
but if you don't know what the [ __ ] that
is yeah yeah you're not gonna you're
gonna be like what
yeah yeah and yeah even that was made
such a big deal of before and and of all
the things paid off i would argue that
that is a
better handled one but even so i mean
that opens up a whole new layer to this
character for us explicitly here that i
think would have been nice to see some
of the history of
back at home when they are finally
reunited or something because yeah like
this all starts off partly with clint
being like this [ __ ] watch from the
auction and everything
and then that becomes more just like a
cheeky detail than it does something
important or poignant yeah like there's
the secret files on here or something
how many guys always a lot of you guys
will come come at us in the comments and
be like i haven't read the comic or i
haven't read the comics for this
so i'm just judging it based on the show
itself
and that's what i mean by this whole
mockingbird thing
is
if you haven't read the comics
how are you possibly supposed to care
about what just happened in that moment
it would probably look like a shield
logo to you or something right like oh
cool
but why does why was she like thank you
you know yeah yeah that was agent 19.
like you build this whole thing with
this watch and it and it just seems like
such a afterthought too yeah oh yeah i
got the watch
it's weird so much of this episode felt
like things got in order to cram it all
in everything became afterthoughts
there's a lot of outlining and uh only a
few scenes that were felt truly
worthwhile yeah and so yeah i was um
i gotta say like i was i was pretty let
down by this episode and uh
you know all the live-action marvel
shows uh this was the only finale that
really let me down
uh i i've had issues with
i think i mean i love the loki one but
i'm pretty sure there's like i have
little qualms i qualms with like every
finale i believe
this is the one where i'm like no i
definitely
feel
this could disappoint
yeah yeah with more
thoughts put into everything with more
resonance put into everything uh so
yeah that's just that's just the [ __ ]
way we feel and that's the way it goes
yeah it's a fun watch in the moment it's
just dissolving now that it's done i've
found myself really trying to enjoy it
and that's why even yeah that's why even
with like elena and and uh clint
i was already so
finding myself bothered by how i was
feeling leading into it that i couldn't
even get that into it at that scene at
the time it became just an observation
of
this is a good scene okay it's good work
between good actors
but it's not hitting the way it could
ensure like yeah that should be
absolutely and for as beloved as elena
has become in a short time that should
if she's gonna be here that should be a
wrenching scene for the both of that
should be the most cathartic point in
the episode arguably
because not only is it cathartic for
elena but it's cathartic for clint and
it's a vulnerable moment that ties into
core history and i do love how much
natasha does feel like she is a presence
in her absence
but yeah
i guess the last thing i'll say is
why did the cop show up at the toy store
first
and not at the ice skating rink first
where there's a mob like fighting a guy
violence and explosions and a tree
falling
yeah you know priorities man they take
everything in order of the call they
receive this it's literally like
whoop i rarely am the guy to think that
but that actually brought me my brain
after a certain point of
where are the cops
there's like no law enforcement here
yeah yeah in new york city of new york
city at one of the most touristy spots
on christmas day
new
york there would already be cops there
before anything even happened yeah
yeah
because it's a bunch of [ __ ] man
a bunch of [ __ ]
that is the most like that wouldn't
happen yeah
i was pretty let down by this um
i mean that that's more of a nitpick of
just like whatever movie mechanisms you
got to have your characters have their
scenes all right i got it but uh
yeah that was uh
all right all right strange episode
merry christmas guys what do you think
leave your thoughts down below
maybe if koi was here we would have
loved it ain't that right koi koi
visible koi cheers
no we've upset a lot of you
[ __ ] is the last episode
[Laughter]
see you guys uh but first patron of the
day shout out
niraj krishnan saving the best for last
because it's a competition at patreon
and this is a perfect episode because
this episode had so many people
grappling for the spotlight when it
belongs
on you my friend plus you're out there
on the east coast you could climb the
christmas tree at the rockefeller center
meet an owl become friends tame the owl
make it carry letters places for you
uh you know
all the things you would want to have at
the holiday spirit you know niraj i
think you should uh do that but anyway
this was a very simple shout out dude
all you had to do was say
that a lot of people were expecting
spider-man to show up in here oh yeah
because of the essene and no way home at
the rockefeller plaza and the fact that
you see raj's musical and obviously
spider-man didn't show up but you know
would have been even cooler cameo niraj
krishnan showing up in this and then
niraj showing up in this episode would
have made us actually really love this a
lot would have subverted expectations
because we don't get our friendly
neighborhood spider-man no we got our
friendly neighborhood naraj krishnan our
friendly neighborhood patron naraj
krishnan it's really simple i don't know
what this whole thing about owls is that
you're doing
like
what what
where did this this was so simple this
was so simple it's okay this was a
master class and i was awe-inspired i
took so many notes like next shout out
for niraj i'm gonna knock your socks off
all right that's next christmas niraj
look out why did you like the matrix
resurrection because it took
[Music]